maya angelou once said each one of us
has lived through some devastation
some loneliness some weather superstorm
or spiritual superstorm
when we look at each other we must say i
understand
i understand how you feel because i have
been there myself
my great friend filmmaker and
philanthropist
tyler perry personifies empathy
tyler knows what it is to be hungry to
be without a home
to feel unsafe and uncertain so when he
buys groceries for one
thousand of his neighbors supports a
women's shelter
or quietly pays tuition for a
hard-working student
tyler is coming from a place of shared
experience
tyler paid for the funerals of the black
men whose names were on the placards at
marches
in atlanta where his film studios employ
thousands
he created camp quarantine making it
possible to safely continue making a
living
everyone in tyler's camp has been given
access to the vaccine
and this was just in the past year
the most generous person that i knew
growing up was clearly my mother
she taught me to never look for somebody
else to be the hero
and never sit around waiting for
chariots find a way
find a way she would say junior you find
a way
[Music]
in that finding a way she would always
encourage me to help someone else
i remember getting out of bed and
literally stepping on someone on the
floor
and i go in the kitchen like who are
these big they needed a place to stay
she didn't have much but whatever she
had she was willing to share so that's
very much in my dna
it is how he was raised that if somebody
reaches out then you reach out to
somebody else and they'll reach out to
somebody else
when covert hit it was really important
for me to get everybody back to work
i'm always the person that says okay
this is happening what do we do to fix
it how do we fight it
he fed all these people
during the pandemic he made sure people
had
what they needed to get through it the
perry foundation has been about
transferring
tragedy into triumph i don't want to
have a foundation that is targeted in
one specific thing because the need is
so great
all over many things battered women
traffic children
poverty homelessness addiction whatever
we can do wherever we can show up to
help
there is no harm in caring he's going to
create opportunities for other people
like opportunities were created for him
he's going to encourage other people the
way people encouraged him
when you've been given a voice there's a
huge responsibility
to use it in a way that sustains change
so he created a living legacy that keeps
on giving
what's better than that this man
exemplifies the best you could ask from
any human
and that is to care about
your fellow human beings it goes back to
my mother
junior find a way find a way
tyler i know you never do what you do
for thanks
but i am grateful for the countless ways
you work to make ours a better
world it is my honor to present to you
the gene herschel
humanitarian award
[Music]
thank you
thank you that is uh
that's incredibly kind thank you so much
they only gave me a few minutes so
i i want to say a very special thanks to
miss viola davis who
is nominated tonight in doing this thank
you thank you i really appreciate it
to the board of governors especially to
whoopi goldberg ava you know when i set
out to help someone
it is my intention to do just that i'm
not trying to do anything other than
meet somebody at their humanity
like uh case in point this one time i
remember i was maybe it's about 17 years
ago i
rented this building and we were using
it for production and
i was walking to my car one day and i
see this woman coming up out of the
corner of my eye and i say
she's homeless let me give her some
money judgment i wish i had time to talk
about judgment
anyway i reach in my pocket and i'm
about to give her the money she said
excuse me sir do you have any shoes
it stopped me cold because i remember
being homeless and having one pair of
shoes and they were bent
over at the hills so it's like yeah so i
took her into into the studio she was
hesitant to go in but we went in
we go to wardrobe and there are all
these boxes and everything around the
walls and
fabrics and racks of clothes so we ended
up having to stand in the middle of the
floor
so as we're standing there wardrobe we
find some shoes we help her put him on i
stand up
i'm waiting for her to look up and all
this time she's looking down
she finally looks up she's got tears in
her eyes she said thank you jesus
my feet are off the ground in that
moment
i i just i recall her saying to me i
thought you would hate me for asking
i'm like how can i hate you when i used
to be you how can i hate you when i had
a mother who grew up in a
jim crow south in louisiana rural
louisiana right across the border from
mississippi who at
nine or ten years old was grieving the
death of emmett hill as she got a little
bit older she was grieving the death of
the civil rights boys
and the little girls who were in the
bombing in alabama she grieved all this
all these years and i remember being a
little boy and coming home and she was
at home like what are you doing at home
you supposed to be at work she was in
tears that day she said
there was a bomb threat and she couldn't
believe that someone wanted to blow up
this place where she worked
where she took care of all these
toddlers it was the jewish community
center
my mother taught me to refuse hate
she taught me to refuse blanket judgment
and in this time
and with all of the internet and social
media and algorithms and everything that
wants us to
think a certain way the 24-hour news
cycle it is my hope
that all of us would teach our kids and
not only to remember just
refuse hate don't hate anybody i i
refuse to hate someone because
they are mexican or because they are
black or white
or lbgtq i refuse to hate someone
because they are a police officer
i refuse to hate someone because they
are asian
i would hope that we would refuse hate
and i want to take this gene herschel
humanitarian award
and dedicate it to anyone who wants to
stand in the middle
no matter what's around the wall stand
in the middle because that's where
healing happens
that's where conversation happens that's
where change happens it happens in the
middle
so anyone who wants to meet me in the
middle to refuse hate
to refuse blanket judgment and to help
lift someone's feet off the ground this
one is for you too
god bless you and thank you academy i
appreciate it
thank you